[Musique]
y'a comme un jouet salaires via la wii
allez c'est difficile c'est parra alors
fallait voilà allez patrick patrick ma
conviction oui
ouais l'amf a way aller la halle et
ouais voilà une frappe aussi la rampe et
dans la boue frappe est allée albert
aller il est mauvais le ballon ça n'est
rien oui voilà une froid alors allez way
pour mieux ça ouais aller au bout ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on attend portrait non c'est quelque
chose que je n'aime pas du tout faire et
je préfère une conversation et c'est
peut-être pour cela que j'ai choisi le
parc des princes car ces thèmes pour
nous le football c'est un lieu
symbolique où se passent toujours les
grands événements et surtout les grands
événements en équipe de france c'est
aussi une année à événement puisque
c'est l'année 78 l'année charnière pour
tout le monde pour les uns en politique
pour les autres en sport et pour combien
en football c'est vrai c'est une année
chargée d'espérance pour beaucoup de
gens mais surtout pour nous puisque
c'est l'argentine et cette qualification
qu'on attendait depuis très longtemps et
qu'on a enfin obtenu en 77
et bien maintenant on y est on y pense
on la prépare tout doucement et bien sûr
que 78 on l'espère sera une date
marquante pour le football français
vous y pensez tous les jours toutes les
nuits vous arriver à dormir
non on n'y pense pas encore trop mais
tout concourt justement a toujours y
revenir il ya toujours un fil conducteur
avec l'argentine et on ne peut pas
maintenant penser agir ou réagir sans
qu'il y ait en toile de fond buenos
aires et les groupes de qualification
vous êtes patron de l'équipe de france
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour assumer ces
fonctions être un meneur d'hommes oh je
ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il faut je
n'ai jamais cherché je crois qu'il faut
être suffisamment objectif pour revoir
tout ce qui se passe exactement sur les
terrains et peut-être suffisamment
costaud pour résister aux critiques
commencent à s'organiser votre vie et la
façon de vous organiser votre travail
est bien l'organisation de mon travail
le rythme de ma vie est très difficile à
définir parce que selon les périodes
il n'y a rien de très précis mais il y a
les stages les stages nombreux des
équipes nationales je dis bien il n'ya
pas seulement que les la première équipe
l'équipe à il y a les stages de
formation de cadres former des
éducateurs
il y à aussi l'observation de matchs de
championnats nationaux de championnat de
jeunes et également des matches
internationaux
et puis il y a essayé d'être toujours au
courant des techniques
en pointe et pour cela il faut aller
voir souvent à l'étranger ce qui s'y
passe et avoir de nombreux contacts avec
tous les techniciens de tous les pays
marc francs sur cinq minutes bien bien
étiré alors comment sélectionne t'on les
joueurs ont plutôt vous quel est le
critère de milan de sélection s'est
passée la technique est ce que c'est
autre chose
les critères de sélection sont aussi
toujours très difficile à définir mais
pour moi j'ai une grande préoccupation
également c'est la qualité humaine
alors j'essaie de marier les qualités du
joueur et les qualités de l'homme et
pour cela c'est bien sûr c'est pas
toujours très facile alors donc
intervient d'abord la qualité
individuelle et après dans les aspects
que qui constitue le football j'y mets
en priorité la tête
c'est très important la qualité
individuelle dans un sport d'équipé
absolument c'est justement dans la
qualité individuelle consent le joueur
qui a le courage de faire passer
l'équipe avant l'homme avant son propre
jeu et c'est bien sur ce qu'on appelle
l'esprit collectif et ce qui doit
intervenir le plus souvent en football
quand on vous a nommé pour diriger
l'équipe de france on a eu l'impression
qu'on voulait attendait un petit peu au
tournant est ce que vous avez eu ce
sentiment
vous vous sentiez guetter un peu oui
j'ai senti lors de ma prise en fonction
de l'équipe nationale une certaine
réticence parce que jusqu'à maintenant
je n'avais jamais dirigé de grands clubs
mais comment peut-on le faire lorsqu'on
est jeune qu'on sort à peine des rangs
de joueurs on voudrait déjà qu'on ait un
passé d'entraîneur
et puis aussi parce que j'avais été
habitué à être un adjoint l'adjoint de
georges boulogne
l'adjoint de stéphane kovacs et on se
demandait si
j'allais pouvoir supporter d'être le
numéro un
[Applaudissements]
vous avez quel âge michel hidalgo
mais je vais avoir 45 ans famas et vous
êtes de quel pays hidalgo star espagnole
mon père est espagnol était espagnole
c'est vrai mais je suis né tout à fait à
l'opposé je suis né à le frein cook un
petit village dans le nord à côté d'une
grande usine
mais toute ma jeunesse je les passais en
normandie jusqu'en 1952 j'allais vous
dire vous avez rien d'un même du nord
non je n'ai pas spécialement non plus
quelque chose de normand mais il ya un
compromis de beaucoup de choses
alors comment vous est venue au foot
vous jouiez enfin un cours d'école eh
bien oui j'ai habité longtemps dans des
cités il ya beaucoup d'enfants et nous
jouions dans la rue dans partout il y
avait un peu de surface si vous dire que
font le foot c'est éminemment populaire
c'est un sport très populaire et très
pratique et d'ailleurs dans le monde
entier et donc on y vient presque
naturellement comme ça entre enfants
avant de d'entrer dans quelque chose
d'organisé c'est-à-dire un club de
fenouil ont pratiqué en même temps lors
des étudiants dans les récréations entre
les heures de classe bien sûr et je le
répète toujours 2
dans la rue et puis après je suis
l'entrée dans un club amateur en lorsque
j'avais 14 ans déjà décidé de faire
votre vie ah non non non en y pensant
même pas puisqu'il n'y avait pas de club
professionnel j'habitais caen mondeville
à côté de caen et c'est un petit peu par
hasard en rencontrant un grand club dans
un match important un match de jeunes
que j'ai été sollicité que mes parents
ont décidé de nous laisser partir mon
frère et moi dans ce club professionnel
en 1952 après et bien j'ai eu la chance
de jouer immédiatement dans une équipe
professionnelle et et en 1954 d'être
transféré au stade de reims une équipe
prestigieuse et qui était un petit peu
le rêve
mon rêve de gosse en ce temps là et je
suis resté au stade de reims jusqu'en
1957 où là je suis allé beaucoup plus au
sud et dans un beau pays où il ya un
beau soleil monaco où je suis resté
jusqu'en 1970 et vous avez arrêté de
jouer quand et bien j'ai arrêté en 1967
pour me consacrer un peu plus
vers une fonction un métier d'éducateur
face les deux est très difficile à un
certain niveau d'être entraîneur et
d'être en même temps joueurs et
d'ailleurs ce n'est absolument pas
recommandé
c'est une c'est un peu lourd à porter et
en 1970 j'ai eu la chance de d'entrer à
la direction technique nationale qui
vous n'êtes qui venait d'être créée en
collaboration avec le secrétariat d'état
de la jeunesse et des sports
quelles ont été vos grands matches aux
fins vous souvenez particulièrement bas
on se souvient surtout bien sûr d'aider
des finales et j'ai eu la chance avec le
stade de reims de disputer la première
finale de coupe d'europe que nous avons
perdu contre le real madrid
hélas et puis on se souvient aussi de
ces titres j'ai eu la chance d'être une
fois international est justement contre
l'italie voyez comme non oui quinze ans
après je retrouverai les italiens mais
sur le banc
j'ai été deux fois chanté trois fois
champion de france et également la
chance de gagner deux fois la coupe de
france donc vous voyez que je peux pas
me plaindre
du football vous étiez une vedette quand
vous jouiez au foot
non non je ne t'ai pas pas du tout une
vedette jeter peut-être classé dans les
bons joueurs français mais absolument
pas l'étoile des quotas et et des
platines et maintenant qu'est-ce que
vous pensez justement du vedettariat
dans le sport et surtout dans le
football c'est vedette est clair comme
ça qui monte au firmament
oui une bien sûr il ya un petit côté
pour l'opinion publique quelquefois
désagréable mais pour nous on ne trouve
pas ça
anti naturel et a aucune raison
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y ait pas de vedette
dans le sport parce qu'ils sont ils font
partie de l'actualité il passionne les
foules il passionne l'opinion publique
il passionne la presse donc c'était un
petit peu pareil et je crois qu'il ne
faut pas être contre un petit peu les
premières pages et la une de certaines
vedettes du sport parce que c'est aussi
intéressant que de voir un ministre que
l'on met en première page parce qu'il
vient de vendre une grande quantité
d'armes par exemple est ce qu'on oublie
aussi quelquefois c'est que pour un
platini un refus tôt en quelques autres
comme ça à combien d'obscurs qui vouent
leur vie au foot pour lesquels à 35 ans
c'est fini
oui ils vouent leur vie au foot mais
d'abord il ils font ce qu'ils aiment ça
c'est important dans la vie et à 35 ans
je n'ai pas encore vu tellement de
footballeur sur les bouches de métro à
paris donc il y a quelques fois une
reconversion difficile mais pour qui
n'est t'elle pas difficile actuellement
qui est certain de faire toute sa ville
le même métier à une des grandes
questions qu'on se pose à propos du
sport général et à propos du football en
particulier particulièrement en ce
moment c'est tous les problèmes du
professionnalisme puis de l'argent oui
on met toujours un petit peu
le mot péjoratif c'est le
professionnalisme dans le sport on
associe malon marie mal mon argent et le
mot sport et pourtant partout dans tous
les métiers dans toutes les fonctions il
y a le mot argent qui intervient on ne
comprend pas pourquoi pas dans le sport
c'est une accusation qu'on rejette
formellement
parce que on ne voit pas pourquoi mes
nuits nous rubinstein ou prodiguerait de
la mue la mauvaise musique parce qu'ils
touchent 3 millions par soirée prenons
le cas concret qui est celui de platini
je pense le cas platini parce que celui
qui se pose en ce moment mais ça veut
c'est un cas général ces fabuleuses
qu'on peut verser un joueur platini et
bien on peut dire que c'est normal que
maintenant ils essaient de monnayer son
talent est au plus haut niveau et que
pour sa seule les pays étrangers peuvent
le faire alors on peut le regretter
pour le public français mais je crois
que lui il ne peut pas résister à tant
d'arguments on est on est ici en plein
bordelais c'est ici chez vous et c'est
vrai vous aimez la nature
oui j'aime beaucoup la nature et je
pense qu'il faut pouvoir équilibrer sa
vie et à travers une vie de voyages de
stage où il ya souvent beaucoup de monde
je pense qu'il me fallait c'était
nécessaire de trouver ce calme cette
nature dialogue avec les hommes c'est
très intéressant mais je crois le
dialogue est la nature est aussi une
nécessité car là il y à vraiment
l'instinct du vrai et du faux
les bleus allaient en place
allez bon ballon à l'est
allez
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
ad
allez allez
si vous deviez dire que la meilleure
qualité de l'équipe de france et sa
bonne tenue
la correction c'est vrai que c'est une
grande qualité qu'on ne met pas assez
souvent en avant dans le sport mais bien
sûr c'est pas c'est pas cette qualité
seulement qui fait gagner les matches et
si l'on doit en ajouter une autre c'est
la générosité n'est pas cette vanité de
croire que c'est moi qui leur ai donné
je pense que ça fait partie de leur
éducation
ça fait partie de leur qualité d'homme
et je pense que je suis heureuse surtout
de toujours préconisé cela et que sans
avoir besoin de leur dire trop souvent
ils le font de même et ils ont pas
l'idée de gagner par tous les moyens il
joue aussi pour le plaisir ça existe
même au niveau d'une équipe de france il
joue surtout pour le plaisir et et je
veux que toujours que dans chaque
maquiller sa demie en avant ce sont des
mots qui paraissent un peu enfantin
maintenant de parler de plaisir de
satisfaction de bonheur mais
personnellement je veux toujours les
mettre en avant et je crois que c'est
souvent ce qui se passe avec nous
cent ans
[Musique]
qui sait
il
non
une fois avec un peu de chance
il
[Musique]
le chauvinisme et quelque chose comme le
nationalisme outrancier en sport ça vous
gêne ça nous gêne mais nous ne rejetons
pas la fête populaire la fête populaire
le saucisson le coup de rouge les
supporters cette grande kermesse nous
intéresse toujours mais bien sûr tout ce
qui est outrancier tout ce qui est de
mesurer
ça nous gêne un petit peu parce que nous
sommes des gens assez simple mais à 48
heures du match la sélection définitif
au match france italie
je vous demande pas qui ça va être bon
le savoir mais ce que vous avez déjà en
tête votre sélection et bien non
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser je
la connais pas moi même
j'attends encore l'entraînement
j'attends un petit peu de réflexion
j'attends encore un petit peu de
concertation avec quelques joueurs et un
quart d'heure avant seulement je
connaîtrai définitivement la composition
de l'équipe
ça ne dépend pas du dernier entraînement
ça dépend d'autres considérations de les
sentir de savoir exactement comment ils
sont physiquement
et puis surtout parce qu'on a besoin de
discussion
mais tout ça ça se fait très vite et je
dis bien dans le dernier quart d'heure
c'est seulement là qu'on bâtit
définitivement l'équipe voici l'équipe
pour jouer contre l'italie équipe sans
surprise presque classique ray janvion
trésor rio bossis bathenay platini
guillou d'alger lacombe rouillé
mais dans ce match amical bertrand
demanes battiston lopez henri michel et
guemriche peuvent entrer à tout moment
et nous profiterons justement de cette
possibilité de changement de trois
joueurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me paraît
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
il aurait demandé surtout le plaisir la
joie de jouer et d'être heureux de faire
un grand match et je leur ai pas demandé
tout de suite de faire un résultat
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on a démarré
lentement et qu'on n'a pas cherché à
peut-être pas assez à mon avis à être
déterminant dans les actions en finale
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et en fin de première mi temps on n'a
qu'un fléchissement c'est chez l'équipe
italienne et avec michel hidalgo on en a
discuté à
nous a dit c'est le moment d'attaquer je
crois que c'est sûr qu'on a fait en
seconde mi temps
je sais pas ça tout ça on a pu arracher
ce match nul
m
[Musique]
la coupe du monde est ce que ça vous
pose un quelconque problème moral la
légion en argentine vous savez que
certains s'élèvent sur le fait d'aller
jouer la coupe du monde là bas dans ce
pays en ce moment
est ce que vous en pensez ben on ne peut
pas ignorer un petit peu tous les
problèmes qui se posent dans le monde
entier mais ce qu'on voudrait dire c'est
quand même que le sport est un pour nous
un langage universel et qu' il n'y a pas
de frontières nous allons en argentine
pour rencontrer des sportifs pour
rencontrer également un peuple et nous
pensons plus à quelque chose de
bénéfique avec ces échanges que si on
éliminait l'argentine et on se demande
d'ailleurs pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment que quelquefois
la politique n'a pas droit de cité dans
le sport et on se demande au fond
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle n'aurait pas le
droit d'entrer là aussi la politique
peut entrer dans le sport jusqu'à
maintenant on a toujours essayé d'être
apolitique de ne pas se dire à droite de
ne pas dire à gauche mais deux autres ça
on se dit en avant et contre
publiquement c'est toujours quelque
chose de difficile mais ce qu'on
regrette c'est lorsqu'il y a une action
à faire pour les sportifs les partis
politiques ne se mouille pas par contre
lorsqu'on essaie de nous exploiter
on essaie toujours de nous faire faire
telle ou telle action où nous faire dire
telle ou telle chose n'est pas le
sentiment que finalement la renaissance
du football français elle est d'autant
plus marquante qu'elle s'épanouit dans
un formidable désert du sport français
en général willy à un désert parce qu'on
n'a pas voulu rendre la nation sportif
on n'a pas voulu faire
la france un pays sportif par
philosophie par atavisme on ne sait pas
pourquoi mais est ce que nous regrettons
c'est le manque d'efforts pour essayer
de d'intégrer le sport dans l'éducation
des jeunes et surtout au niveau scolaire
et au premier cycle et surtout de
de dhimmis et le sport français le sport
tout court dans la société actuelle vous
sportif vous admirez des grandes nations
sportives comme je pense les états unis
lurs ou l'allemagne los angeles par
exemple eh bien oui nous sommes obligés
d'admirer ces pays parce qu'il ya une
belle jeunesse et une jeunesse sportive
qui est naturellement à moins de
problèmes avec les aspects de la vie
actuelle nous pensons que la pratique du
sport n'est pas simplement pour se faire
plaisir et d'avoir des satisfactions en
pratiquant telle ou telle discipline
mais pour nous il ya un facteur
important est qu'on n'est pas assez en
avant c'est le facteur bonne santé et je
crois que dans les millions de jeunes
qui pratiquent que ce soit dans football
ou autre chose il n'ya pas un seul
drogués et quand on sait la fortune
qu'il faut pour prévenir et peut-être
pour faire les les cures à aux 300 400
mille jeunes drogués
ce sont les chiffres que l'on nous donne
je crois qu'on devrait se pencher un peu
plus sur le sport si vous aviez des
responsabilités gouvernementales en
matière de sport qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que vous diriez non merci beaucoup je
suis très bien à ma place
non mais ce qu'on essaierait c'est
justement donner une résonance une
importance plus grande pour le sport et
je crois que ce serait vraiment de
mettre quelque chose grandes vertus en
avant
[Musique]